president biden shows the world that his
empathy is an act with a blame-shifting
nasty vindictive and bloviating speech
championing his afghanistan withdrawal
and the fallout will be toxic i'm
benchmare this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with
vpny trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and plenty of it there is
first let me remind you that if you're a
responsible adult you need to get life
insurance because you just don't know
what is lurking around the corner you
could be just walking down the street
and suddenly you are attacked by a mob
and that mob just leaves you for dead
and there you are lying and you're just
lying on the ground you're thinking
yourself i should have had life
insurance because now who's going to
make sure that my family's bills are
taken care of this is why you need life
insurance i mean also we're all going to
die so you need life insurance anyway
and this is very dark early in the
morning but that's just the way that it
is you could save 50 or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers all in one place why
compare well you could save 300 bucks or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies
licensed experts and policy genius work
for you not the insurance companies so
you can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews across both trustpilot and
google
and eligible applicants can now get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call head
on over to policygenius.com shapiro to
get started right now and get the best
life insurance policy at the best
available price policygenius.com
shapiro to get started right now when it
comes to insurance it's nice to get it
right policy genius alrighty so
remember that time that president biden
was supposed to be the king of empathy
and this was his entire pitch sure he's
doddering sure he's not coherent sure he
has nothing but bad ideas and even
barack obama once said don't
underestimate joe biden's capacity to f
things up but he's so empathetic i mean
he's just he's grandpa he's the guy that
you want in a tragic scenario to put his
arm around you and really make you feel
better about life that's the guy you
need joe biden
it's bull it's bull okay
and this is becoming increasingly clear
because what true empathy
is about just interpersonally is when
you don't agree with the person that you
are empathizing with and when you have
to take the brunt of what they are
saying and just internalize it
okay if all your empathy really is is
performative if all your empathy really
is is calling upon your own wellspring
of personal grief in order to project it
out to the world so that people will
sympathize with you that is not you
acting empathetically that is you being
an actor and joe biden is an actor
i don't know what else to tell you when
it comes to his supposed compassion and
his supposed empathy what we have
watched over the past several weeks is
the stripping away of the veil of
empathy from joe biden it happened again
last night it's been happening
consistently over the past several weeks
when asked tough questions about the
suffering of the people being left
behind in afghanistan when he has asked
about the people who are going to be
living under the taliban
and the people who are going to be
murdered by the taliban joe biden has
shown no empathy when it comes to the
american service people who came home in
caskets from afghanistan joe biden has
shown little or no empathy the only time
joe biden ever seems to be able to
muster up even an iota of empathy is
when he invokes his his son beau who
died of brain cancer at the age of 46
and that has nothing to do
with the soldiers who died in
afghanistan for example it has nothing
to do with the suffering of the people
under the taliban or the people who
worked with us who will be undoubtedly
executed that has nothing to do with
anything it turns out that human beings
all over the course of history have had
personal tragedies in their family
okay relying on that personal tragedy to
suggest that you understand all grief
everywhere or that your grief
is
suddenly
akin to the grief of others who are
experiencing completely different
circumstances is quite foolish and quite
empty and yet that's what joe biden does
on a regular basis and i point this out
only because the redeeming feature of
joe biden according to his greatest
advocates is this empathy and yet it's
been not only not on display over the
past several weeks it is completely
absent in fact it's reversed joe biden
is not only unempathetic to people who
deserve his supposed empathy
he is downright cruel to them i give you
a couple of examples to begin today
because that's really what his speech
was about last night it was about no
empathy for the people left behind no
empathy for the people the 38 million
people now living under the predations
of the taliban
it was about defensive bloviating
nastiness
which really is which abiding is
politically people have known this on
capitol hill his entire career he's a
know-nothing he he has spent his entire
career being wrong and when challenged
he gets incredibly combative and grumpy
and nasty to people and you see it with
the press all the time
his empathy only extends so far as it is
politically useful for it to extend
that is the real story of joe biden
politically
and it is the story of him as president
of the united states at this point
his empathy extends to people who agree
with him and who massage him
it's a couple of examples so you'll
recall that the president of the united
states went to dover air force base to
greet the incoming caskets of 13 service
members who were killed in kabul
in large measure thanks to his garbage
policy of allowing the taliban to
provide security for people trying to
get out of the country and also of not
holding bagram air base so we had no
actual security buffer
so the the parents of many of these
members service members went to dover
air force base and biden wanted to meet
with them and so they did
their stories are
somewhat chilling on an emotional level
because
george w bush during the
afghanistan war during the iraq war he
routinely used to call parents of people
who had fallen service members who had
fallen given their lives in service of
country
he routinely used to go quietly to dover
air force base without press coverage
without the media there snapping his
photo
he used to do that all and he used to
take abuse from people he used to take
all the understandable emotional rage
that parents were directing against him
and he used to just take it
not so joe biden so here's the account
of mark schmitz he's the father of
gerard schmidt who died in this suicide
bombing in kabul talking about his
encounter with joe biden
well initially i wasn't going to meet
with him
but then i felt i owed it to my son to
at least
have some words with him about how i
felt and uh
it
it didn't go well
um
he talked a bit more about his own son
than we did my son and that that didn't
sit well with me
according to schmidt joe biden started
talking about beau and he said i'm not
really interested in hearing about beau
right now i want to talk about my son
since my son was the one who's just
killed in the line of duty
and instead of biden understanding that
biden actually got angry
instead of instead of biden
saying
i hear you and you're right
instead
biden got mad at him
okay same sort of story from darren
hoover the father of marine staff
sergeant taylor hoover another fallen
service member he said that joe biden
couldn't stop checking his watch over
and over and over
in reference to
the
checking of his watch
that didn't happen just once
that happened on every single
one that came out of that airplane
it happened on every single one of them
they would release the salute
and
he looked down his watch on every
last one all 13
he looked down on his watch
schmitz
seconded that motion the other father he
said i actually leaned into my son's
mother's ear and i said i swear to god
if he checks his watch one more time and
that was only four times in i couldn't
look at him anymore after that
considering especially the time and why
we were there i found it to be the most
disrespectful thing i've ever seen
jen saki by the way dodged when asked
about whether biden was looking at his
watch he was asked directly about this
yesterday here was the press secretary
of the united states who essentially has
become joe biden's night nurse every
evening joe biden does something to crap
the bed and then every morning jens
hockey comes in and has to clean it up
here she was trying to dodge the
question about whether joe biden was
checking his watch let's just remember
for a second that if donald trump had
done this if he had gone to a ceremony
for fallen service members with the
caskets coming off the plane and he had
been checking his watch
can you imagine the outro the outcry and
the the justified uproar here is uh
here's jen saki
was the president looking at his watch
and does he have a message to those
people
who felt that they were offended
i would say his message to all of the
family members who were there those who
were not even in attendance is
that he is uh grateful to their uh sons
and daughters the sacrifice uh they made
to the country that he knows uh
firsthand what it's like to lose a child
and the fact that no one can tell you uh
anything or say anything or there's no
words that are going to fill that hole
that is left by that
okay so they're just going to say empty
words about all of this and this is what
joe biden does all the time right
something bad happens and then he talks
about what it feels like to be in grief
as though somehow this is supposed to
make him
empathetic he's going to talk about his
own pain and this makes him empathetic
no
talking about somebody else's pain makes
you empathetic talking about your own
pain especially as a politician
makes you
selfish
and it makes you unlikable
and it makes you a user
which is what joe biden is let it not be
said that his afghanistan policy is
rooted in any sort of empathy it's
certainly not rooted in strength or
indecency
but the the pitch again is that no
matter what joe biden is well
intentioned and empathetic that is just
not true we'll get to more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the simple fact that you don't want to
go to the auto parts store why would you
would you want to stand in line for a
long time and then get to the front then
finally they ask you a bunch of details
about the car you answer them and then
they're like yeah bro we're gonna order
it online then we'll up charge you
show up in two weeks
no or you could just go online and do it
yourself go to rockauto.com they always
offer the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why spend up to twice
as much for the same exact parts the
rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you okay so
this empathic policy has now resulted in
a wide variety of people being left
behind in afghanistan those people
include apparently
24 students from sacramento who are
still stranded in afghanistan according
to the sacramento quote at least 24
sacramento area students are confirmed
to be stranded in afghanistan as turmoil
continues in kabul according to school
officials san juan unified at school
district staff said 24 students down
from the initial estimate of 150
students had not returned to campuses
since the start of the 2021-2022
school year
apparently staffers at the sacramento
congressman ami bera's office contacted
san juan unified and are working with
the district to bring the students back
safety safely but they are still stuck
there
meanwhile
it turns out that a three-year-old has
been stranded there as well
the three-year-old boy was born near
sacramento according to abc 7 news his
passport shows he's a u.s citizen he's
going through a harrowing ordeal right
now unable to escape afghanistan or
hiding his identity and that of his
father a social worker and other family
members who are all us permanent
residents for fear of them being
captured by the taliban so as you will
learn pretty shortly from joe biden
himself probably what happened is that
they called the three-year-old and they
didn't pick up the phone so really is
his own fault that he is stuck there
other people who are stuck there include
an afghan interpreter who saved joe
biden's life but now is stuck there
according to the wall street journal 13
years ago afghan interpreter muhammad
helped rescue then senator joe biden and
two other senators stranded in a remote
afghanistan valley after their
helicopter was forced to land in a
snowstorm now muhammad is asking
president biden to save him hello mr
president save me and my family muhammad
who asked not to use his full name while
in hiding told the wall street journal
don't forget me here muhammad his wife
and their four children are hiding from
the taliban after his years-long attempt
to get out of afghanistan got tangled in
the bureaucracy they are among the
countless afghan allies were left behind
when the us ended its 20-year military
campaign in afghanistan on monday
asked about this
jensaki thanked the interpreter for his
service and said the u.s remains
committed to getting afghan allies out
of the country yes i'm sure i'm sure
meanwhile the state department is
telling people you know just keep a low
profile if you're a green card holder
and you're still in afghanistan yeah
just keep your head down we'll probably
be fine
according to jim garrity reporting for
national review the u.s embassy in kabul
suspended operations on august 31 to
2021 while the u.s government has
withdrawn its personnel from kabul they
say we will continue to assist u.s
citizens and their families in
afghanistan from doha qatar which is
like 600 miles away we'll also continue
our efforts to help lawful permanent
residents
they say that u.s citizens and their
families members still in country should
quote keep a low profile and notify a
trusted person of your travel and
movement plans and make contingency
plans to leave when it is safe to do so
that do not rely on us government's
assistance
so yeah that we're not leaving people
behind it all such empathy such dramatic
empathy meanwhile the taliban continues
to perform reprisals by the way the us
government left its own journalists
behind afghanistan according to josh
rogan at the washington post
the administration was warned early and
often about the 600 or so employees
contractors and family members who
worked for u.s sponsored news
organizations under the umbrella of the
u.s agency for global media a federal
agency funded by congress they include
journalists working for voice of america
and radio for europe who have worked in
afghanistan for years of great personal
risk the taliban has killed four rfe
journalists since 2016 through suicide
bomb attacks the company's journalists
routinely received death threats from
the extremists now the leaders of these
organizations say the state department
promised to get everybody out before
august 31st only to later renege on that
promise amid the chaos and confusion at
the kabul airport by the way i'm
receiving notes from people who are
actually at kabul airport when all this
was happening and there were apparently
many situations in which the airport was
filled with people ready to evacuate and
then they were just emptied out and
handed over to the taliban
senator ben cardin democrat of maryland
he says it's disheartening so many
professional journalists employed by
american-funded news organizations have
now been left behind with their families
these afghan allies are among the people
most endangered at the present moment
for the good work they have done over
the course of the last two decades
meanwhile the taliban of course is going
around and killing people
according to the bbc there's growing
evidence that the reality on the ground
is different than the rhetoric coming
from the taliban no shock wow i can't
believe it you mean the taliban has been
lying to the international community
about how they treat people that's crazy
we trust those people they're our
friends now
now sources inside afghanistan as well
as some who recently fled have told the
bbc taliban fighters are searching for
and allegedly killing people they
pledged they would leave in peace
several sources confirmed taliban
fighters last week executed two senior
police officials
haj mula ahazkai the security director
of badgis province and ghulam sakhakbari
the security director of pharaoh
province video footage shows aksai was
kneeling blindfolded his hands tied
behind his back before he was shot and
murdered
so things were going great over there
and this is all because of joe biden's
empathy you see he's really an
empathetic dude so in one second we're
gonna get to joe biden's speech last
night which was breathtaking and it's
arrogant astonishing in its temerity and
this is a president who apparently has
never made a mistake ever this whole
thing was beautiful it's all trump's
fault but it was beautiful
we'll get to that in just one second it
really is an amazing amazing thing first
if you're having trouble falling asleep
or staying asleep one of the best things
you can do is start getting enough
magnesium a lot of people do not get
enough magnesium over the course of the
day don't just run to the store and buy
the first magnesium supplement you find
many magnesium supplements only use the
two cheapest synthetic forms since
they're not full spectrum they won't fix
your magnesium deficiency or help you
sleep better there are actually seven
unique forms of magnesium you have to
get all of them if you want to
experience the calming sleep enhancing
effects of magnesium and that is why i
recommend magnesium breakthrough by by
optimizers you simply take two capsules
before you go to bed you'll be amazed at
how much better you sleep and how much
more rested you feel when you wake up
it's really important obviously to get
enough sleep and if you've got a
magnesium deficiency that is something
that could interfere with that for an
exclusive offer for my listeners go to
www.magbreakthrough.com
shapiro use code shapiro10 to save 10
when you try magnesium breakthrough oh
and also for a limited time buy
optimizers is also giving away free
bottles of their best-selling products
p3om and mass enzymes with select
purchases go to www.magbreakthrough.com
shapiro get your exclusive 10 discount
plus the chance to get more than 50
bucks worth of supplements for free go
check them out right now at
magbreakthrough.com
shapiro alrighty so
last night more than 24 hours after we
found out that the american military had
left joe biden decided to give a speech
joe biden
had basically been hiding in the
basement
because the fallout from this is bad
it's really bad it turns out that when
you leave hundreds of american citizens
behind
and then when you leave probably
thousands of american green card holders
behind and tens of thousands of sv
holders behind
and a myriad number of afghan allies who
worked with us and millions of people
who actually don't want to live under
the predations of the taliban it turns
out you don't look empathetic it turns
out you look like a piece of bleep
that's what it turns out you look like
and when you do so in absolutely
cowardly fashion
refusing to answer questions from the
press giving mush mouth statements
every couple of days lying
overtly throughout the entire process
talking about how everybody will get out
talking about how we're going to stay
long enough to get everybody out talking
about how every contingency here was
planned turns out people don't like you
it turns out they think that your
empathy is merely an act at that point
and they are right and you can see this
in joe biden's poll numbers which have
now sunk into the low 40s
and after being dead solid at 50 his
entire presidency he is now down to
about 40 41 in a lot of these polls
and and falling fast because he is not
competent and he is not capable and he
is not the quote-unquote empathetic
grandfather figure that so many people
thought they were electing
that is the takeaway so joe biden goes
into hiding yesterday he doesn't come
out
he has his secretary of state tony
blinken give a full ridiculous speech in
which he looked like he was delivering a
hostage video he's looking slightly off
camera at his cue cards
he had the centcom commander kenneth
mckenzie go out there and humiliate
himself by saying a bunch of stuff like
the taliban are now our best friends and
we handled this beautifully
and finally joe biden emerges after
delaying his speech right he was
supposed to give his speech yesterday
about 1 30 eastern time and then it was
about 2 45 eastern time he was supposed
to speak and then finally he came out
after three o'clock which is his normal
way he isn't
he i don't know what's going on behind
the scenes over there but they have not
hit a time for him to like they're much
better about hitting timelines in
coordination with the taliban than they
are with actually keeping their schedule
with regard to the press right they
routinely call a time when he's going to
speak to the press and then they just
kind of blow right through it so finally
he emerges and he proceeds to give a
30-minute diatribe
and he really was a diatribe he is angry
he is he is grumpy
he is pissed off that you have
questioned his obviously wonderful
strategy
he blames every single person but
himself he has done everything
absolutely perfectly this thin-skinned
buffoon
everything he has done here was part of
the plan except when it wasn't part of
the plan and if it wasn't part of the
plan that's everybody else's fault but
his
joe biden has said repeatedly the buck
stops with him the american public are
holding him to that right now but he
doesn't want to be held to that he's
lying he wants the buck to stop with
trump he wants the buck to stop with the
afghan military he wants this buck to
stop with his own military commanders
he is hiding behind everybody for the
for the one decision that he made and
only he made which was pull out right
now damn the consequences
okay everybody else is to blame
everybody the people who are stuck in
afghanistan are to blame
they're the ones they should have just
gotten out earlier obviously
the president of the united states is a
pathetic spectacle
at this point in time
and once again
the the key to all of this is
understanding that it has utterly
undercut his image of himself and his
image on the world stage not because
everyone thought he was an expert not
because everybody thought that he was
fluent in foreign policy that was a
creation of the press it was always a
myth joe biden was never fluent at
anything
a man's terrible at everything he hasn't
made a good foreign policy decision his
entire career
and he's he's so bad on foreign policy
he opposed the bin laden raid now of
course he uses the bin laden raid as an
excuse to get out of afghanistan but he
opposed it at the time
he's that no one was under the if you
had watched joe biden his entire career
no one was under the impression that
this guy was any sort of einstein
i mean the guy wasn't even a sixth grade
science student
joe biden has always been horrific in
terms of policy
okay but
the one thing that was said for him and
this was again his entire pitch against
donald trump his entire pitch it was not
my policy is going to be better than
trump because his policies were not
going to be better than trump polls
showed americans actually liked trump's
policies better than bidens his entire
pitch throughout 2020 is i am a nice
person i am an empathetic person i am a
person who cares donald trump the
cruelty is the point is adam sir
famously said the cruelty is the point
with trump but i joe biden i am the
repository of all good humane
compassionate feeling
that has been completely exploded over
the course of the last four weeks he
ain't getting that back the impression
that joe biden is somebody who cares
deeply about america about american
citizens that this is somebody who you
know many times over the course of his
campaign
he tweeted that he's going to build a
society where we leave no one behind and
now he is physically leaving behind
americans with the worst people on earth
the taliban
and actually i should say like the
second or third worst people on earth
because actually the taliban is not even
as bad as al qaeda or isis which the
taliban is currently hosting
right this is this is a guy who who
posed as he was going to unify america
around solidarity and instead he's been
divisive and said he has been awful and
again his compassion only extends as far
as the front of his face that is it
it extends as far as a mirror
joe biden is compassionate to one person
and one person only joe biden which is
why when he speaks about grief he
doesn't speak about anybody else's grief
he speaks about his own personal
experiences of suffering and grief
he did it again in his speech last night
so
yeah take that for what you will
but if a politician has one pitch and a
pitch incompetence
and the pitch is not coherent the pitch
is i'm a nice person and then that falls
apart you have to ask yourself what
exactly is his pitch for staying
president at this point
what is the pitch and the answer is
there is no pitch
he proved that last night
in extremis it's it's
pretty amazing we'll get to that in just
one second first
if you've not refinanced your mortgage
in the recent past or if you are looking
at refinancing your mortgage right now
you really should check out my friends
in american financing america's home for
home loans now is a great time to refi
because the fact of the matter is that
you could spend a few hours over the
weekend and save yourself over twelve
thousand dollars a year right just prep
that mortgage refi at american financing
that's a lot of money 12 000 bucks a
year it's an opportunity that currently
exists when you refinance that mortgage
with american financing talk with an
expert mortgage consultant learn about
custom loans that might fit your budget
better no pressure no obligation no
friend or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around ways you can save up
to a thousand bucks a month it only
takes a 10 minute call to get started so
what exactly are you waiting for
pre-qualify for free at
866-721-3300 that is
online at 866-721-3300
nmls 182 334 mls consumer access dot org
again check them out right now at
americanfinancing.net it's eight six six
seven two one thirty three hundred eight
six six seven two one thirty three
hundred or americanfinancing.net to get
that home refi started okay so as i
mentioned before when it comes to
politicians i don't think you should
look to them for empathy i don't think
policy should be rooted in empathy i
think it should be rooted in what is the
most practical what is the most
practical and what is most in america's
interest
but joe biden doesn't believe that joe
biden believes that policy should be
rude in empathy so if he is
unempathetic
he has nothing else to back his policy
because his policy is obviously not
pragmatic his policy is obviously not
effective it is not useful and so he is
left spinning in circles and that's what
we saw last night so the president
toddles out to the microphone
and he proceeds to declare that what he
has done is triumphant he's triumphant
about all of this
and we've been giving you the updates
i mean we gave tens of billions of
dollars in american military equipment
to the taliban we've got thousands of
americans and american green card
holders who are stranded behind enemy
lines we have china and russia on the
move
uh no quick note yesterday the taliban
were not apparently hanging somebody
from a helicopter it was just somebody
taking a joyride beneath the helicopter
we'll wait for a couple of weeks for
them to actually hang people beneath the
helicopters in any case here was joe
biden yesterday beginning with a
triumphal announcement of what he joe
biden had done
last night in kabul
the united states ended
20 years of war in afghanistan
the longest war in american history
we completed one of the biggest airlifts
in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
that's how good this was it was a
historic win for the united states to
turn over the country back to the people
who committed 911 or provided cover for
those people it's a historic win
you know how many people we evacuated
from the titanic here man we are good at
evacuating people from the titanic what
a plan what a masterfully conceived plan
well what about you might be asking
yourself what about the 13 dead service
people because you decided to hand
security over to the taliban joe biden
has an answer for you
they did it facing a crush of enormous
crowds seeking to leave the country
and they did it
knowing isis-k terrorists sworn enemies
of the taliban
were lurking in the midst of those
crowds 20 service members were wounded
in the service of this mission
13 heroes gave their lives
i was just at dover air force base
for the dignified transfer
yeah checking your watch every five
seconds and insulting the military
parents by the way does he ever mention
here why it was that uh they were facing
a crush of enormous crowd seeking to
leave the country
and why they had to face down isis k
terrace at no point does he actually
mention this the reason this happened is
because he gave up bagram air base which
exists outside of kabul the reason that
this happened is because he decided to
hand over local security directly to the
taliban the washington post has reported
instead of taking the taliban's own
offer of allowing the united states to
maintain control of kabul at least long
enough to evacuate our people
at no point is he going to take the
blame for that even though this is again
a complete biden policy see everything
was masterfully handed handled
and the military's challenges well those
were those were natural those were just
how things were going to be
okay then he starts the blame game
so remember captain compassion over here
he uh the the blame game is so normally
if you're compassionate you normally say
you take the hit you move on not joe
biden this is everybody's fault but his
so he starts by ripping into the the
collapse of the afghan government and
lying about it he says that he was uh
that he had contingency plans for the
collapse of that guy and it was it was
sort of foreseen that's we know that's a
lie in july he was explicitly telling
people it would not be like the fall of
saigon that the taliban did not have the
ability to take over the entire country
quickly he himself said that by the way
he was lying at the time he was lying at
the time there's another story from the
daily mail today july 23rd
that that biden actually called
the now departed afghan president ashraf
ghani and he saw that the taliban had
been making gains and he asked gani to
lie about it
he asked gani to say to everybody that
everything is going fine apparently
it's not a great phone call guys i've
noticed that impeachment happens over
phone calls these days that's not a
great phone call biden apparently
said to ghani he that he wanted
gani to lie to people he said quote i
need not tell you the perception around
the world and in parts of afghanistan is
things are not going well in terms of
the fight against the taliban there is a
need whether it is true or not there is
a need to project a different picture
okay so you knew things were going badly
and he told ghani to lie about it
here was joe biden explaining however
that you know we had an assumption about
the afghan military holding it turned
out not to be accurate no one could have
predicted this but we had contingency
plans number one a lot of people did
predict it number two he knew what was
going on and number three he did not
have a good contingency plan
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate
but
i still instructed our national security
team to prepare for every eventuality
even that one
and that's what we did
they did they prepared for every
eventuality so many eventually now who
are you gonna believe joe biden or your
own eyes
clearly they did not prepare for these
eventualities
and clearly he was putting artificial
constraints on his own military i mean
mark milley said as much he said we were
told that we could have six to seven
hundred troops if by the way their
contingency plans have been so excellent
why did we have to reinsert thousands of
troops on the ground in order to
effectuate this evacuation
and if there was such a great
contingency why are there still
literally tens of thousands of people
who made promises who still stuck there
okay so uh so he continues along these
lines we made contingency plans this was
so incoherent on the one hand it's the
afghan military's fault on the other
hand we made contingency plans on the
one hand it's trum's fault on the other
hand i deserve all the credit like he
was all over the place because when you
don't have an actual defense you just
have to throw at the wall and that's
what joe biden is doing right here
so he continues along these lines
so we were ready
when the afghan security forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country
and losing thousands of their own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected
we were ready when they
and the people of afghanistan watched
their own government collapse
and the president flee
amid the corruption of malfeasance
handing over the country to their enemy
the taliban
and significantly increasing the risk to
u.s personnel
and our allies
okay so again everybody's to blame it
was all part of the plan but the afghan
military completely collapsed and that's
because they're corrupt and terrible so
i just have a question for joe biden at
any point here are you going to mention
the fact that you completely withdrew
close air support as well as all
american
there was an available
an excellent plan for the evacuation
which doesn't explain why we have all
these people still stuck on the ground
over there and no personnel but
according to biden all part of the plan
and you have to be a to believe
him you really do you have to be a com a
clinically stupid person in order to
believe this stuff here's joe biden
talking about the wonders of his plan
as a result
to safely extract american citizens
before august 31st
as well as embassy personnel
allies and partners
and those afghans who had worked with us
and fought alongside of us for 20 years
i had authorized 6 000
troops american troops to kabul to help
secure the airport
as general mckenzie said
this is the way the mission was designed
it was designed to operate under severe
stress and attack
and that's what it did
okay so if you design the mission then
who's to blame for leaving the taliban
in control of security and getting 13
american service members killed
but it's either your planner it ain't
your plan which is it
okay but then this also leaves a
question if this was such a
well-designed and brilliant plan why are
there so many people left behind enemy
lines right a normal plan you said you
were going to take care of every
contingency a normal plan would have you
know dealt with the fact that we now
have at least hundreds of american
citizens behind enemy lines and an
unspecified number of green card holders
by the way remember how at the very
beginning of this they were saying there
were 10 to 15 000 americans in kabul
remember how that trunk all the way down
to 6 000. you wonder how that happened
it's because they started excising
anybody who's a green card holder if
you're an american green card holder you
no longer count if you're somebody with
legal papers you're no longer counted so
they just redefined who got to count as
an american for purposes of getting them
out even though green card holders have
the same rights from the us embassy as
american citizens proper
that's how they played the statistical
game anyway you might be wondering if it
was such a great plan designed by this
brilliant
piece of of human genius
then why are so many people left behind
joe biden has an answer
the collapse of the country was the
afghan military's fault not his he had a
plan and the evacuation if it was
unsuccessful with regard to these people
that is their fault that three-year-old
we talked about earlier that
three-year-old we told them over and
over you need to come to the airport and
the three-year-old just kept crying and
watching elmo nothing we can do about
that here is your biden blaming the
people who got left behind
since march
we reached out 19 times to america
in afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
afghanistan all the way back as far as
march
after we started the evacuation 17 days
ago
we did initial outreach and analysis
and identified around 5 000 americans
who decided earlier to stay in
afghanistan
but now
wanted to leave
our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than 5
500 americans out
um okay so here he says well you know in
march we were telling people to leave
yeah and in july you were saying the
country definitely was not going to fall
so which is it dude
okay so then he gets to the people who
are still left and he says you know what
their fault
they wanted to stay probably all these
people trying to get out probably their
fault
everybody's fault except for this
daughtering fool
now we believe that about 100 to 200
americans remain in afghanistan
with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long time residents
but early decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans there
is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
if they want to come out but they don't
want to come out right it's their fault
they're stuck there obviously i mean
that's clearly what's happening right
there by the way i do love when he uses
stats like 90 of americans we got them
out now they're saying it's 98 of
americans right they're trying to
downgrade the number of americans who
are actually stuck there even though
they still don't have exact numbers
90 of americans well you know it's
unbelievable here's here's an
unbelievable stat for you you ready on 9
99.99
9 i believe 99.999 percent of americans
were not killed by terrorists on 911.
isn't that amazing wow what an amazing
success story that was incredible
like truly inspiring
the president of the united states here
okay in a second we'll get to him
continuing to make excuses uh him
continuing with his false binaries and
his straw men
this is a pathetic spectacle for the
united states he's completely destroyed
american interests in the near east and
in in central asia and um he has done so
while destroying his own reputation by
the way whatever was left of that it is
now in tatters we'll get to more of the
president of the united states making a
fool of himself on national television
yesterday first let us talk about high
quality sleep so bowlin branch knows
that high quality sleep does not stop at
your mattress they're ultra soft organic
sheets are transparently sourced
produced in safe fair conditions you
will feel a difference and know you're
making one as well founded in 2014 by
husband and wife scott and a missy
cannon it all came down to a choice to
do what's right woolen branch was
founded to give more sleepers more
choices for high quality sheets at a
fair price their sheets are by the way
fantastic i have them on all of my beds
you know the bed the kids beds all of it
we got rid of all of our other sheets
they're that good the signature hem
sheets are beloved bestsellers for good
reason they get soft with every single
wash experience the comfort of a buttery
soft lightweight sheet in a 100 organic
cotton sateen weave that is perfect for
all seasons they come in a variety of
colors and sizes they are made up to a
higher standard toxin-free processes
fair trade certification to experience
the best sheets you've ever felt choose
bull and branch today you can try them
worry free for 30 nights free shipping
free returns and my listeners get an
exclusive 15 off your first set of
sheets with promo code shapiro at
bullandbranch.com that is b-o-l-l and
branch dot com
promo code shapiro bowl and branch dot
com promo code shapiro two gets starting
at 15 off your first set of sheets of
bowling branch they're the best sheets
on the market all righty we'll get to
more of our daughtering present in just
one second first
big announcement once a month the host
of daily wire we come together for
backstage we do some lighthearted debate
we dissect the trending political and
cultural topics in the moment sometimes
it gets serious as it did last time i'm
super excited to tell you backstage in
october is going to be staged a little
differently instead of just tuning in
from home you will be able to see us
live and on stage at the ryman
auditorium right here in nashville doing
what we do best making sense and also
jabbering at one another and i'll eat a
lot of popcorn so join me jeremy boring
michael knowles matt walsh and clavin
and candace owens for a backstage like
never before and we have a super special
offer if you are a daily wire member you
have a special 12-hour window to buy
your tickets ahead of general admission
that starts tomorrow thursday september
2nd at 10 a.m central so you need to
become a member now because that means
you have a 12 hour window where you get
to buy the tickets first before anybody
else check your email for a special code
you can use to pre-order your tickets if
you're not a member you're just gonna
have to wait until tickets go on sale
this friday september 3rd no guarantees
it won't be sold out by then we have a
lot of members so go become a member and
then you get a special ability to get
the tickets early if not you'll have to
wait mark your calendar make sure you
don't miss out you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden continues along
these lines he has to find more people
to blame right so he's already blamed
the afghan national army he's blamed the
afghan government he's blamed the
americans themselves for being stuck in
kabul and now he is going to blame
everybody who doesn't trust the taliban
right we really should trust the taliban
it's very important to trust the taliban
you might be wondering you know okay
fine so you're blaming the americans
sort of left behind but what are you
going to do about them joe biden's
answer is we're going to trust the
international community and the taliban
what a joke this human being is
just yesterday
the united nations security council
passed a resolution
that sent a clear message about the
international community expects the
taliban to deliver on moving forward
notably freedom of travel freedom to
leave
and together
we are joined by over 100 countries that
are determined to make sure that taliban
upholds those commitments
those countries do not include russia or
china as i have noted but nobody else
seems to to care uh and and you're
asking yourself now why would we trust
the taliban why and joe biden says well
they did make public comments
and i mean there's one thing that's
clear the taliban are people who keep
their word they would never lie about
anything and if they do lie man we will
punish them using this fluffy bunny
right here we will we will threaten to
withhold this fluffy bunny we have made
it with our own american hands this
fluffy bunny
and we will we will not give it to them
if they do not let the americans out
or alternatively we'll just send them
bags of cash here's the president of the
united states talking about why we can
rely on the taliban
the taliban has made public commitments
broadcast on television
and radio across afghanistan
unsafe passage for anyone wanting to
leave including those who worked
alongside americans
we don't take them by their word alone
but by their actions
and we have leverage to make sure those
commitments are met
the leverage comes in the form of our
massive military power we just withdrew
and also the incredible leverage we have
over the money that we hold you know we
have capacity to hold like their bank
accounts and and we can totally withhold
those bank accounts if they if they oh
wait they have american citizens over
there so yeah we are kind of going to do
whatever they want to do okay then joe
biden had to spread the blame around
because it turns out that no matter how
much horse manure he he tries to turn
into gold it's still horse manure so
he's got to spread it around right
everybody's got to get dirty so again
just to recap the people who are to
blame are americans stuck in kabul
the afghan national army
the
as we'll see he's going to get to trump
next and then he's going to get to his
own military commanders everyone is to
blame except for the only one who made
the call this jackass
and so here he was going after uh going
after donald trump
let me be clear
leaving august the 31st
is not due to an arbitrary deadline
it was designed to save american lives
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban to
remove u.s troops by may the first just
months after i was inaugurated the
previous administration's agreement said
that if we stuck to the may first
deadline that they had signed on to
leave by
the taliban wouldn't attack any american
forces
but if we stayed
all bets were off
he continued along these lines and then
he laid out the false binary either we
left in ignominious defeat and left a
bunch of americans behind and rushed out
of there based on a deadline set by only
one person joe biden
or we're gonna have to go to total
cataclysmic war there's no evidence to
suggest this is the case he's just
pulling this directly out of his ass
this is the same exact sort of logic
that was used with regard to barack
obama's iran deal which was there are
only two choices nuclear annihilation
with iran or this crappy deal i bring
you right joe biden is doing the same
thing here our only two options we're
not to maintain the status quo with
every so often a ratchet up of troop a
ratchet down of troops no there are only
two options either complete pull out or
complete utter warfare tens of thousands
of americans dead in the streets
it's just nonsense it's just nonsense
but again this is his shtick
so we're left with a simple decision
either follow through on the commitment
made by the last administration and
leave afghanistan
or say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
that was the choice the real choice
between leaving or escalating
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
okay that one is going to come back to
bite him i was not extending a forever
exit because i promise you we're going
to be carrying out operations in
afghanistan for some time to come if he
plans on keeping any of his commitments
the only way that the quote unquote
forever exit is over is if he really
does mean to abandon all of these people
okay so
he wasn't done spreading the blame so
it's trump's fault
even though again the trump deal with
the taliban was conditional and i was
not a fan of the trump deal with the
taliban i thought it was crappy at the
time i spoke out about it at the time
i think that there are a bunch of things
that the trump administration did with
the taliban that were frankly
unconscionable i think the release of 5
000 prisoners at the behest of the
taliban was insane and ridiculous and
unrooted unmoored from reality
but there's only one person who decided
to surrender the country in its totality
that's joe biden by the way joe biden
blaming trump is kind of amazing
considering last week he said himself no
matter what trump had done he would have
done this
once again joe biden speaking out of
both sides of his mouth but that may
just be because he has lost all
elasticity in his face at this point
in any case joe biden then decided it's
not enough to uh to blame trump he's
also going to blame his own military
advisers if you if you're blaming me
blame the military too what what a man
he is standing for his own strategy and
his own plan standing for his principles
this way what a what a brilliant orator
and an incredible leader here he is just
crapping all over his own military
advisors
the decision to end the military lift
operations at kabul airport was based on
the unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and military advisors
the secretary of state
the secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field
uh
nope nope maybe based on the artificial
conditions you put on them but i love
how it's everywhere but everybody else
advised him to do this you see it really
wasn't his call it was his call because
he's so smart and because it was such a
great move but also it was trump's fault
and the afghan military's fault and the
americans stuck in afghanistan's fault
and his commanders told him to do it so
really the buck stops with all of them
unless you like the decision in which
case the bus stops with biden captain
empathy over here someone pathetic and
then he says and now join me in grateful
prayer to me since i'm the one who made
the decision
for now
i urge all americans
to join me in grateful prayer
for our troops and diplomats and
intelligence officers who carried out
this mission of mercy
in kabul
and a tremendous risk with such
unparalleled results
when he says i want you to give a prayer
for the troops and diplomats and
intelligence officers what he really
means and we all know it is i wish for
you to give a grateful prayer to me
i'm the master of this policy i was the
creator of this policy unless you don't
like in which case it was really
everybody else but
it was so brilliant and so well done i
mean it kind of failed but but true he's
he's all over the damn place and the
reason he's all over the place is
because this is a bad policy and he
refuses to own it and it didn't spring
from empathy it sprang from bull headed
stupidity
which really should be the name of his
next autobiography bullheaded stupidity
would be an excellent name for an
autobiography by the current president
of the united states now in just a
second we'll get to his actual
justification for the decision not the
strategic decision but the geostrategic
decision why was it necessary that we
pull out of afghanistan right now okay
so joe biden's speech continues and here
he really gets to the meat after he's
done blaming everybody else here he gets
to the meat this is why joe biden had to
make the decision to leave afghanistan
now when we had 2500 troops on the
ground zero combat casualties since
february of 2020
a foothold to fight terrorists al qaeda
and isis to prevent the retaking of the
country by the terror housing taliban
here is why it was necessary that we
pull out and also how he made no
mistakes right so first of all let's
just start with this
you know a lot of people were asking joe
biden
why didn't you pull people out sooner
right if you thought that we needed to
to get out and august 31st was the
deadline why didn't you start the
evacuation sooner according to joe biden
joe biden has never made a mistake that
is the answer
compassionate empathetic joe biden he
has never made a mistake here he was
i take responsibility for the decision
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done had
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
imagine
if we've begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war
there still would have been a rush to
the airport
a breakdown of confidence and control of
the government
and it still would have been very
difficult and dangerous mission
because he now is going to rely on
counterfactuals what if there had been
like a massive civil war and we had
evacuated people that had been rushed to
the like he has no proof of any of this
here's what we do know you collapsed the
afghan government from within you
collapsed the afghan military from
within you handed over kabul to the
taliban you allowed the taliban to
control security and you left a bunch of
americans behind and if you're asking
him could you have done it any better no
way man it was inevitable inevitable
okay so here's where he gets to the
justification for his grand strategy his
geostrategic thinking and what it really
comes down to his geostrategic thinking
is i wanted to do it so i did it
that is his geostrategic thinking
because
all he can pose as an alternative
is straw men a giant field of straw men
burning to light up the night here is
the president of the united states
explaining that there was no way to get
out without it being really rough but
also you know if you wanted to stay for
years on end what would have been enough
you know what had been enough what was
going on right then the status quo was a
lot better than this here's joe biden
the bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war
that you can run without the kinds of
complexities
challenges threats we faced none
there are those who would say we should
have stayed indefinitely
for years on end
they asked why don't we just keep doing
what we were doing
why do we have to change anything the
fact is
everything had changed
my predecessor had made a deal with the
taliban
when i came into office we faced a
deadline may 1.
the taliban onslaught was coming
okay that is not what the intelligence
sources were saying that we were on the
verge of a giant taliban tet offensive
nope because you know what the afghan
military had been taking 10 15 000
casualties a year they had close
american air support
so the evidence of this is pretty much
non-existent but joe biden continues to
rely on this in the same way that again
the the obama administration relied on
the lie that there are moderates in iran
who are emboldened by our nuclear deal
with them
okay and then he continues along these
lines and it is incredible how
delusional this old man is truly so he
says that you know our national interest
had been fulfilled in afghanistan
he which is
frankly a completely insane thing to say
here he was continuing
to those
asking for a third decade of war in
afghanistan i ask
what is the vital national interest
in my view we only have one
to make sure afghanistan can never be
used again to launch an attack on our
homeland
remember why we went to afghanistan in
the first place
because we were attacked by osama bin
laden and al qaeda
on september 11
and they were based in afghanistan
we delivered justice to bin laden on may
2 2011
over a decade ago
al qaeda was decimated
okay there's something that i've noticed
in the recent past
al qaeda is back
yeah the president of the united states
saying that the only reason we're there
is to prevent terrorists from taking
over afghanistan
hmm
i've noticed the people you just handed
afghanistan to are the exact same people
we fought in 2001 and i've also noticed
that all the terrorists who were there
in 2001 are rushing back in that isis k
carry out a terror attack on american
targets in kabul in the middle of your
garbage evacuation plan i noticed that
the al qaeda leaders have been
rearriving in
afghanistan by the way like every major
defense official understands that we
have just reconstituted a terrorist
state in afghanistan joe biden's like
yeah we had to leave because it was over
there was no more terrorism problem now
we left and the terrorism problem is
back there's a damned shocker
okay and then he just starts
pulling non-sequiturs off the trees i
mean this is just bizarre he starts
talking about why aren't we in yemen
i mean we're not in yemen because we
weren't attacked from yemen and if we
had not been attacked from afghanistan
and it had not been a terror haven we
wouldn't have attacked afghanistan
your answer is like so
so
and
here's captain incoherence
i respectfully suggest you ask yourself
this question
if we've been attacked on september 11
from yemen
instead of afghanistan
would we have ever gone to war in
afghanistan
even though the taliban controlled
afghanistan in the year 2001
i believe the honest answer is no we
succeeded in what we set out to do in
afghanistan over a decade ago
then we stayed for another decade
it was time to end this war
who's president for most of that decade
or a large part of that decade that
would have been barack obama was it not
by the way you know who opposed the obl
raid that would have been this guy this
idiot
again i'm spending a lot of time on this
because i think this is the only true
justification for what joe biden just
did that we are going to get which is he
has a pigheaded stubborn and idiotic
view of how world affairs works and he's
going to cram it down and he does not
give a damn who pays a price for that he
doesn't care how many americans will
have to die in afghanistan to make that
happen he doesn't care how many
americans will die here if the
terrorists come back he doesn't care
about any of that he had in his mind
that he was going to do this and that
was it it was going to get
done okay he he then continues along
these lines this is just
so
again the speech is all over the place
he actually in the middle of the speech
he's like we're out we're never going
back also we might go back
that was this portion of the speech
we will maintain the fight against
terrorism afghanistan and other
countries
we just don't need to fight
a ground war to do it
we have what's called over the horizon
capabilities
which means we can strike terrorists and
targets without american boots on the
ground or very few if needed
we've shown that capacity just the last
week
we struck isis k remotely
days after they murdered 13 of our
service members
and dozens of innocent afghans
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
um
so uh i noticed that one of those really
really great drone strikes may have
killed an entire family
and that might be because we didn't have
eyes on the ground and we were relying
on the taliban to do our spotting for us
maybe that was part of the problem
also it turns out that launching a drone
attack from six hours away in qatar is
not exactly the same as having close air
support with americans
on the ground and american contractors
on the ground and american allies on the
ground
afghanistan is going to turn back into
the black box that it was in 2001 that's
going to be jobiden's fault but i am
enjoying the irony of joe biden saying
we've withdrawn it's over and also we're
going to fight you to the ends of the
earth isis k
alrighty then he continues and he says
you know what the really important thing
is that in withdrawing from afghanistan
we've done severe damage to china and
russia this may be the most delusional
thing in the speech and this is a speech
filled with delusion it's a speech
filled with crazy
he says you know china and russia they
wanted us to stay in afghanistan really
because they seemed pretty enthusiastic
about us leaving
the u.n security council resolution
calling for free travel was not joined
by china and russia because they're like
yeah man us is out let's make friends
with the taliban got some rare earth
minerals they're providing us another
built-in road target they humiliated the
americans we're we're up for this and
joe biden's like you know who's really
upset today the russians and the chinese
and vladimir putin is sitting up in his
bond villain mansion going
here is joe biden
idiot
and here's a critical thing to
understand
the world is changing
we're engaged in a serious competition
with china and there's nothing china or
russia would rather have would want more
in this competition in the united states
to be bogged down another decade in
afghanistan
um
so um yes that's exactly what china and
russia wanted was for us to stay
weird because they're pretty happy that
we left
okay finally joe biden gets to the sort
of biden doctrine okay the problem is
that he's lying so he says that there
are only two principles that you got
american foreign policy
and um it is difficult to argue with
these two principles the problem is that
jobiden doesn't actually hold by any of
these principles here we go
as we turn the page
on the foreign policy
this guided our nation our nation the
last two decades
we've got to learn from our mistakes
to me there are two that are paramount
first
we must set
missions with clear
achievable goals
not ones we'll never reach
and second
we must stay clearly focused on the
fundamental national security interest
of the united states of america
okay so a couple of things here one he
says we have to set missions with clear
achievable goals oh um i've noticed that
you have been saying that equity should
be the guiding principle of all american
domestic policy also you want to sign on
to climate change agreements that have
no clear definable goals end dates or
actual strategies involved and also you
say that you want to stay clearly
focused on the fundamental national
security interest of the united states
would that involve handing over
afghanistan to the taliban and the
chinese or would it not
what do you define as the clear national
security interest of the united states
the reality is joe biden's actual policy
is weakness at home and bloated
incompetent weakness abroad and bloated
incompetence at home that's the actual
biden doctrine surrender abroad and then
get fat and suicidal at home that's
that's the plan for joe biden
and he sets up a couple more straw men
here he talks about how that we're
ending an era of major military
operations to remake other countries um
but and then and then he says don't
worry we're still going to be at war
with terrorists so again it's this
incoherent back and forth
it's it's utterly nonsensical and he
talks about how you know we're going to
support the afghan people through
diplomacy because again squeaky bunnies
are going to make this happen when
military force has not
but perhaps the most galling line in in
all of this he uh he talks about the
spending in afghanistan
understand this is coming from a
president who has proposed 10 to 12
trillion dollars in new spending in the
united states
you know to be cleared this year
that's what he has proposed
he's seeking to pass a 3.5 trillion
dollar budget right now on top of a 1.1
trillion dollar infrastructure plan on
top of a 2 trillion stimulus plan
earlier this year but he's really upset
about spending guys this guy is a fiscal
hawk joe biden
after more than two trillion dollars
spent in afghanistan
costs the researchers of brown
university estimated
would be over
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
in afghanistan for two decades
yes
the american people should hear this 300
million dollars a day for two decades
you take the number of one trillion as
many say that's still 150 million
dollars a day for two decades
and what have we lost as a consequence
in terms of opportunities
i mean that's an enormous amount of
spending you know like 300 million
dollar a day for for two decades uh that
two trillion dollars spent over the
course of 20 years that's a lot of money
and
it is a lot of money it also happens to
be a fraction of what he has proposed to
spend this year alone
fiscal hawk joe biden coming in from the
sidelines here okay he concludes his
little speech of course with a reference
to beau because after all it's all about
the empathy guy everybody else is to
blame we're leaving people behind people
can get slaughtered in the streets it's
about the empathy and how do you know
he's empathetic because his son died
that's how you know that joe biden is
empathetic because how many times can he
lean on a tragic story and it is a
tragic story in order to show that he's
empathetic
at a certain point when you just keep
invoking your dead child in order to
get past political hurdles
it seems opportunistic and gross
we passed that point long ago with joe
biden a long time ago siri was invoking
beau biden who did not die in combat
bobine who died at the age of 46
tragically from brain cancer and joe
biden's had plenty of tragedy in his
life right he lost his first wife and
his baby daughter in a car crash the
man's law there's no question
but
what does that have to do as they say
with the price of tea in china it has
nothing to do with anything
when in doubt joe biden goes to the my
son died of brain cancer and so you
should feel bad for me well guess what i
don't feel bad for the president of the
united states he's the decision maker
his decision-making is garbage he
deserves all of the blame he deserves
all of the blowback
and
inevitably when the cons
the consequences of this will be felt
for decades as those consequences become
clear he ain't going to be able to rely
on the fact that people feel bad for him
because what happened to his son to get
him out of it here is joe biden invoking
beau cynically i mean just cynically
we've been a nation too long at war
if you're 20 years old today
you've never known an america at peace
so when i hear
that we could have should have
continued the so-called low-grade effort
in afghanistan
at low risk to our service members at
low cost
i don't think enough people understand
how much we have asked of the one
percent of this country
who put that uniform on
willing to put their lives on the line
in defense of our nation
maybe it's because my deceased son beau
served in iraq for a full year
oh he's going to bring out bo here i'll
just note here there have been 35 000
calls to veterans affairs about suicidal
veterans since the beginning of this
pull-out
if you talk to veterans of the afghan
war
you're gonna be hard-pressed to find any
of them who agree with joe biden's
policy here or think it's good or are
going to be sympathetic to joe biden
because his son served in iraq and then
died years later of brain cancer
it's so opportunistic it's so cynical
and it's so
unempathetic it's fundamentally
off-putting
and then of course dividing left without
taking any questions because that's what
this man does he will not take questions
you won't want to answer questions you
have challenged him he got angry at you
the old man yelled at you and the clouds
and blamed everybody but himself and in
the end the media will end up kissing
his feet because this is what they do
their lap dogs they'll come back don't
worry here is joe biden leaving
thank you and may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
troops by the way that he refused to
protect you you think he's going to come
back and answer question nope he forgot
his mask he forgot his mask so he came
back for that
what a grand and glorious president we
have right now well the media is already
rushing to joe biden's defense i already
have some members of the media who are
doing it naturally
you have people like chris cuomo who's
tweeting out in defense i mean he can't
find a despicable human being he won't
defend chris cuomo he tweeted out trump
handed the keys to a bunch of barbarians
biden extended months from this original
dead from this original date biden
didn't play cards well enough but he was
given a bad hand from trump none of
these angry patriots on the right were
as bothered then as they are now
wonder why well because this hadn't
materialized then some of us were not
happy with the taliban negotiations
right i was pretty clear about that at
the time go back and listen
but chris cuomo coming out in strong
defensive biden is the most predictable
move of the day meanwhile msnbc's rick
stengel was out there defending the
president along the most bizarre lines
here was rick stengel defending joe
biden
here's a disastrous withdrawal
when the british left afghanistan in
4 500 troops left kabul
and one englishman
11 days later arrived in jalalabad that
was a disastrous evacuation here's
another one when the british left india
in 1947 1948 just pulled out over the
next few years two million people died
as that country was divided in half
uh and
and so the idea is here that this is a
big success by the way the british
withdrawal from afghanistan that ended
with that disastrous withdrawal was
1842. don't remember a lot of airplanes
in 1842 these are the geniuses in the
media coming to the defense of joe biden
like the good little lap dogs they are
nbc news doing it too
they tweeted out earlier today
that um you know the real problem here
is of course you wait for it republicans
weaponizing it it's that republicans
have kept weaponizing this thing nbc
news actually had the temerity to tweet
that out republicans are wielding the
issue as a political weapon against
president biden and hope it will damage
the democratic party and help them
recapture control of congress but will
afghanistan matter to voters experts
doubt it well you know if you quote a
couple of experts then probably it won't
matter at all
and here's the reality maybe joe biden's
right
maybe it won't matter at all but if it
doesn't matter to americans that joe
biden abandoned
abandoned human beings to the taliban
for no reason other than his own pride
and vanity then we deserve whatever we
get already we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today he discusses the
story of the gop congressman missing in
afghanistan you can hear more details
about that over on michael's show that
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the united states proposes foreign aid
for the taliban a judge takes a child
from his mother until she gets vast and
a teacher flies the antifa flag in the
classroom check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]